all right JP for good puppet is our
extra you got to do it now times [ __ ]
hmm hmm yeah can't fire a guitar guy is
that you can't fire a guitar guy yeah
can't fire guitar guy
I missed you yeah the guy was just the
cat part our he's everyone's favorite
person Wow that's me Wow
I was bored waiting for JP what do you
want me to do for the love of God
whatever you do if you get into car with
a purple dragon on it do not ever play
it ever why just don't what if we have
to it's like the red button don't push
it
I push red buttons all the time everyone
always pushes the red button don't like
that's a guaranteed certainty do not
mess with the dragon mark do you have a
dragon I would recommend you play have a
dress good I don't trust you not because
you're not my friend I don't think JP
can hear you he knows he years look how
close he is to his picture there he
knows everything
Ryan really peering in on us thanks but
what does a purple dragon look like is
it a dragon that's purple on a card yeah
whatever you do avoid that especially
right now cuz I'm down to two car okay
cool cool yeah yeah good I'm glad that
we're on the same page there black oh
that's not I don't actually have one Oh
yellows good stick with yellow mmm no
all right that was a bluff I wanted blue
I mean doesn't really matter it's okay
cuz you're not gonna survive the dragon
you don't have it right right I don't
have it right right right
no dragon no dragon maybe I'm ready to
help get a drink oh what a drag you're
the dragon all right you don't know
thanks for that thanks for that I can't
play it well okay all right all right
part of the card says way to win part of
the
cards no no don't don't no not no all
right that sucks I don't know you don't
have blue so draw some no I don't have
blue or do I do if you can do something
to mark right now why I feel like that
really stopped mark didn't good job
everybody good job everybody this just
go ahead and play that okay well you
guys are just being a big ol sack of
poopy poopy out of your sex maybe if you
thought we were a team so I'm gonna play
this just because I'm curious all right
all right here's yellow and green you
don't know that and how many horses Bob
have we don't know well you don't know
what I have seat now it's all up in the
air you have no idea what I have now oh
it's just a mystery my hand just for the
recommend oh no I know is that right no
one knows oh good it's green that's a
good color except for [ __ ] it isn't
because everyone hates green it's the
least respected of the colors that seems
a little harsh blue number one most of
the earth is covered in more people like
green than yellow profit actually most
the arocs covered in blue I guess but
whatever green it's also good green is
the second best color after blue green
everyone hates yellow and everyone hates
[ __ ] brown colors like the you could
possibly claim that I listed everyone
wait are you are you saying that in the
same way that that political commentator
said that oh thanks bro you're welcome
yes 82% of people believe what he wanted
people what he wanted them to believe
because he felt like that was true but
he didn't actually check or check any
numbers or no because there's no I'm
just speaking for the sake of speaking
whoa look at that
Oh
fancy foot boards the marking [ __ ] Bob I
will [ __ ] [ __ ] your eyes a good
talking I will [ __ ] grass here all right
I'll get [ __ ] we're all demonetized we
got a rally together and not [ __ ] oh god
why I'm making it worse I'm making it
worse I may be worse this time when you
challenge I don't know I don't know play
some of those sweet cards you got there
buddy all right I will
that's right see I'm smart what I
actually realized the first one I jumped
in on I would have been fine it was when
I've jumped in on the second one I was
once you made it your own color yes I
was fine on the first and then I made it
worse I'm just the biggest idiot in the
world I have no idea what I'm doing my
turn I guess my turn now you got jumped
ahead it's over
mom's jumping no one's going high
jumping Oh buddy that's just that's
unnecessary so listen my hand is very
evil whose turn is it mine I'm not
looking at your screen you don't know
what I'm doing
get your hand out of your pants and the
other hand out of your ass this is not
in your pants I am the funniest man on
the face of the earth
enjoy this punish JP for I don't have to
play they don't wanna I don't wanna
yeah I know whose turn is you don't have
to play mark don't worry about the
punish Bob now [ __ ] you I might not play
this entire time because you asked
why you suck you suck off you suck it's
your turn play or it turns play already
whatever yeah whatever
right cuz I we were yelling at the bot
now and now we have to yell at JP cuz JP
might as well be a bot he is a box it's
a bot
Wow I'll jump in sorry is that the
dragon that's the dragon yeah what's
wrong with that dragon that varies nice
that way this works is one person gets
down to two cards everyone else that's
30 and then it [ __ ] reshuffles all
the cards what's wrong about that
everyone's got 30 each stop eh I don't
think eating is the thing you should be
doing with high yeah I really did it
there guys I did it there nice jump
thank you okay thank you thank you I got
a five for you but I'm gonna play for ya
I want to stick with the color scheme
okay do this I got two for you
take that boy know what the Botwin
whatever we do guys I want the Botwin I
don't you don't do what color yes yes
yes JP you know what to do yes that's
the thing to do that's get him daddy
all right cool what you got what you go
what you gotta wait what color do you
want all right [ __ ] I said tell the
truth I don't want green you don't want
me to be happy that's what happened to
uh for that one moment now I want you
nothing but happiness I don't believe
you all right I lied about green cuz I
think you're gonna listen so [ __ ] me I
guess
[ __ ] me I guess [ __ ] me I guess well
that doesn't the stance doesn't seem
fair I gave you exactly what you wanted
all right all right Bob here Jesus yeah
Merry Christmas yeah yeah yeah okay well
all right Bob this is my only of this
color all right well it's my it's all I
can do you know you all understand why I
did that in a minute
mark has two yellows by the way you're
gonna you're gonna do me like that
you're do me like I can't do a thing
about it but if anyone knows don't worry
heart oh please just pay our way for me
to just pave the way to let me win
course I'm gonna [ __ ] good [ __ ] ah
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you robot [ __ ] you
Oh bot that's what you get that's what
you get I hope you guys have some
attacking red cards you could shove on
to mark that's what you have to what do
you say what you say to me your ally the
troops get it's a nice guy here never
oh well now no one's happy I'm not happy
Wade's not happy nobody happy I'm very
upset
weight has only Reds left by secret miss
nice work JP good play and listen listen
I have no choice here Bob but if this
comes and Wade wins I'll be happy be
happy I'm gonna be happy well that kind
of worked out nevermind I've got a thorn
in my ass
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
no no way in hell no way there's there's
no way in two tits of a rat's ass I'm
Scott he's got two yellows with
right well I got not jumped over by
someone so there's - yes - tits of a
rat's ass that I said you said a [ __ ]
psychopath I literally just came out of
your mouth vibrate of your vocal cords
that smells like chicken sandwiches
still floating around your face there's
no way - tits of a rat's ass mark did
posted marks hundred percent
don't try to put the blame on me he's
really trying to let way to win he owes
me one for all your amazing car Wow why
are they out of order how does he even
do that I'm gonna do you appreciate that
you've wasted a card I guess no no I was
spending cards and tell her I definitely
want my hand wait it's so good okay cool
JP this is a real stinker huh you really
got nothing going on over here
[ __ ] this card's disappeared into the
fart cloud that is mark tornado though
Oh guys right there Paul wait wait do
you have some yellow stuff to play let
me let me show you what I got
peace neat Reno about some
this Pro bro huge up against stuff this
will be able to hit JP with that sweet
loot that's not fair
thanks bro thanks bright the JP is
agreed I don't know what 505 Bobby you
did that because we Wayde and I were
trying to hit him with the dab and you
stopped us I'm not here for anyone but
myself
that's the mentality I was told to have
and you still lost we're gonna let
bygones be with this head Bob we're
gonna be bygones bygones bygones I don't
want a bygones no sorry peace offering
peace offering
peace off it's a peace offering body you
can't reject it I know I gave you a
peace offering and I am confused because
this is a good offering it was one less
card that would oh my god this is a hand
oh I will hear boom goddamn Oh sick play
dude you should see what I got
goddamn it oh yes ready for this boom
I'm gonna change the color now yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh what a sweet all right
that's all I got for you
someone could have done something there
Wow who could have done something
there's like a jumpin there's some
collusion going on somewhere my secret
has to come out alright yeah
that's my secret I had another one cool
all right can we just leave the color a
[ __ ] loan for goddamn @ JP JP JP I
know I q JP I like you wait no I don't
like you wait I thought that was just a
normal while why is he playing with a
controller that's a nice one I'm glad I
had all those cards for that so everyone
could get some good stuff yeah okay wait
do some oh you should see my hand I
could see your hand if I chose to yes if
it's really what you desire much cause
to be obsessed
[Applause]
alright well not wait to be upset I'm
fine yeah we'd be mad be mad be mad be
mad go don't calm down wait my feathers
are so [ __ ] wild they're up my ears
and in my note I'm just good continue
[ __ ] more things with your teeth yeah
there's a dizzying action going on in
this game alright
God Romo of a nice blue 5 which [ __ ]
me royally so now I'll draw wait I want
to challenge you to not curse okay we're
at least one round okay done well it's
the 2012 in 2015 wait didn't I can do it
yeah what happened to you in life I
found a way jeff goldblum was correct
life finds a way
yeah well see that's just the thing I
don't like oh that's a poopy diapers
right there that's a not fun time I tell
you what
oh sweet miss a marriage back you skip
my turn
well well I just I just you know
sometimes you got to do what you got to
do
that's good I wanted to play this lovely
eight there you go have a frog cjp it's
all I wanna do is give you a nice little
eight but you jumped me oh here you go
now a jump ball because I'm also a jerk
face okay all right okay all right okay
all right trying I'm trying here okay
I like this one's better nice butter
nice sweet sexy six okay Oh let's just
take a look I guess and see what's going
on no no no no this whole it's okay lady
baby I don't want to do that I I
resisted the urge to Joe because it
would have made Wayde win I want
everyone to know I am a [ __ ] hero I
can't fix this and all I have is red
here oh good make your own I'm here well
we can all draw I'll just draw wait wait
all right well nice place there you not
good people
that seemed like it was entirely your
fault Wade okay
slightly possibly all been entirely my
fault hours before that I should have
won but Marc stole it from me my best
you played the zero which took away my
happiness I don't want you to
be happy watch clear you succeed in what
you did are you happy now
no you're dead inside like my first
hamster that I actually dropped the
shoebox on the day I brought it home
just inside all over do you guys know
that story no I don't know that story
why my uncle bought me a hamster okay
like a little glass jar from some weird
creepy shop on the way home from like a
trip to West Virginia Wow the day I got
home I would and it bit my finger so I
flung it and it hit a shoebox that had
my shoes in it and that whenever I flung
a to hit the shoe box hit the ground and
then the shoe box fell on it and smashed
it and killed it yikes
and then I buried it in that shoe well
what do you got there mark take a look
take a look yeah I was like six years
old or so I was pretty young five
actually all those numbers are still
very young when you could say any of
those cigarettes of stuff for you're
still like in the womb five-year kid
four year in the womb and six you're an
adult sure okay
the harsh world we live how I feel that
ya guys know everyone be intelligent
here he has a yellow all right I don't
know he has a yellow understand here
okay whatever yes poor hamster but it
wasn't my fault I was a baby that
responsibility should have never been
put up Wow Wow Wow not a baby you said
you're five or six four five or six I
could have been in the wars not a baby
how long were you in their womb are you
kidding before you might as well still
be in the womb no oh you're drinking
milk from the tit and you're sleeping in
a crib 100 live five here it's soda pop
and six you're drinking beer no way life
works
oh hey Mark do you want to ask some fun
yeah man yeah you know and then this
isn't the fun I ordered oh this is the
wrong kind of fun fun fun we're playing
a serious game here I'm seriously
serious about it I don't have time for
your [ __ ] about sperms and stuff
anyone under the age of 40 is still a
toddler 40 ma yes six or adult
twenty-nine your toddler twenty-nine huh
keep going mark keep going no I don't
have one of those Oh wonder what twenty
is gonna pick I don't know how many
cards Bob has that mystery is killing me
so anything is probably not what you
think it's not the right way the same
number you had you didn't have any
[ __ ] yellows though you say I got it
put me bum bum what what's put ear bum
bum it what are you all of okay you guys
wait my mom curse again because you not
cursing makes less sense than you
cursing I made you a promise and I'm
gonna honor okay you're right the rest
of the year I want the old Wade back
that's what I miss oh oh
cuz I'm young now I get it
I'm gonna do that enjoy that mark some
of this Bob a payback's a [ __ ] trusted
you when I wasted my sweet reversal
heart of my card
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's impossible
JP is here JP tell him no it's
impossible he was talking it's
impossible wait
oh sweet ones everybody thanks man it's
a one party [ __ ] you live and
are you what are you doing it there calm
dog tits I don't have a green dog tits
dog tits I don't have a green oh dear me
well well I can play that all right
listen man feel like they're still here
no choice I'll see you made me draw 6
cards like two hands ago no I didn't I
didn't make you why everyone was part of
that you why do you think I'll be harder
for cards and you initiated it
everything you just did so I'm gonna
challenge you and I'm gonna win this
look oh that's not so good see wait are
you gonna blame you getting six cards on
me as well because I know if anything
goes Bob's exactly that's what I was
saying you did this here mark thank you
thank you thank you you know what you
did to know and you did it all right
here who me you're wrong right there
in the past tense you have done it
everyone knows I don't know what I'm
doing so there you go oh why reveals you
don't know what you did doesn't mean you
didn't do it loud I was intending Bigley
I was intending to do it to JP I didn't
think JP had heart cards
oh yeah right what what let's do this
got them wait wait if you have any
dangerous cards I can help you direct
them at shape never mind
all right I'll help you direct them at
JP apparently jump in on yourself JP I
could do this give you some well I don't
want to I don't want to hurt mark I want
to hurt JP oh you don't both okay I want
to hurt mark oh no you don't watch this
it's almost like I knew that was in
there teamwork oh I don't think you are
sorry I don't think you are
he's got two blues boys you know it's
the best treatment you don't know if you
have that I'm giving you an opportunity
to [ __ ] oh oh I don't have anything that
really hurts somebody that works that
works
okay okay I really panned out now hey
you have any more greens oh you have
some more greens look at that okay
listen listen what what good is that
Robo oh look at that that's tasty I know
yeah that's fine I'll take marks and you
can have that no thank you
that's a weird one I just heard wait
I'll help you a more common way Cruz
right that was good see I held off on
using that on you Bob I do I do
appreciate that
oh well Red's not a good one right
listen I can only do so much
we had a peace offering at the beginning
of this you remember two years ago when
we started this game we had a peace
offer
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I don't want to and stop it I said go
again you know what you lose your hand
your hand it's like the mystery and the
shadows is the one you definitely don't
want it's a good hand MA that's a good
hand okay Christ no that's a good color
color you keep that goddamn color in
there it's a good color don't change
that color this my hands actually not
bad there bud that's not bad that is not
bad that's a little hand you got
at their height that's not okay this
tight hand is not gonna do me any good
this hand is getting loose situationally
tight hand I collect you take my turn
we're gonna play the eighth it's fine
whatever
I cursed again sorry Marco oh well you
got to get the punishment oh we both
agreed on and lined up yeah you know
what it is we all know what it is
I know what it is they know what it is
you see me we all know what it is yeah
yeah that's not what it is that was a
pretty uncool thing Wade that's fine you
know I don't know wage is probably good
it's just like he was making sex sound
so boy oh boy
if I cry during that's getting real hey
going in no mark I want you to be happy
at Wade don't do it wait don't wait
don't
okay you're didn't oh okay well okay no
it's not bad Green's fine I dislike you
immensely well literally no choice it's
fair if you want mark to win fair play
yeah you're sick wait what's let the
[ __ ] wait I've been on your side this
whole time I'm on your side but if you
win you have to go
I was on your side buddy I I was I'm
really tried I really did
[Laughter]
[Music]